[Music]
in kicks for kids news submitted by JJ
loves JK oh cool JJ Abrams's watch I
[ __ ] J I sent a movie please or JJ Mucha
you I went to junior high with him
I went did you have with him Nike is
launching a sneaker subscription service
for kids what does that mean for kids to
make more of their shoes yeah so they're
starting this subscription because are
there sweatshops in that's yeah so there
it's kind of like a sneaker club called
Nike Adventure Club
and so this program is designed to make
shopping easier for parents of little
kids so they have kids sizes from 4c2 7y
or about from roughly ages 2 to 10 and
they have these different pricings so
well first of all they have this box
that comes in with the kids name on it -
oh that's cute that's dope yeah and then
it also comes also these are the types
of plans
so there is a there's a $50 a month
where you get new shoes and activities
every 30 days so that's 12 days don't be
dumb any pair of shoes yeah well their
feet are growing fast maybe yeah and
then $30 a month for six pairs for every
60 days or $20 a month for four pairs
every 90 day that one it's probably the
best how fast do kids feed the groans so
they're saying that children over three
years old grow one half wait one half of
foot size every four to six months no
and so they're saying that older kids
only really need to replace their shoes
twice a year if they don't excessively
where I replace my shoes once a year
once a year that's what I got - yeah I
feel like I had like the same pair of
shoes to buy our own [ __ ] and
hand-me-down once yeah I just draw all
over them put thumbtacks in them dude
all kinds of [ __ ] with them bro I had
this pair of earwax that was so dirty
almost like I'm all like clean them and
make them all extra nice and make it
like brand-new and then like you know I
like the white kind of gets kind of
yellow yeah so I took like white out and
I painted over like the little a does
anyone remember the air walks that had
to care it under the tongue no one
remembers this like an actual carrot oh
no like it had a little like embroidered
carrot but it was like under the tongue
just like it so they were all black but
they had a carrot and I swear to God I
make up my poor [ __ ] family because
you were allowed to get one pair of
shoes for every school year yeah so I
wanted these [ __ ] shoes with the
carrot on it and they were out of my
size by like a half size everywhere we
went and I was like um commercial I
don't remember like I think one of the
store clerks like showed me the pair and
I fell in love with them skaters shoe
like it was someone's shoe no it was
like just like a model that they had
yeah but he just had it was all black
with a carrot under it and then I
finally found my size but at that store
they also had air walks that had like
hologram like like it was like black
with like sparkle hologram and yeah then
mimic
and I ended up going with those [ __ ]
got this little [ __ ] it took me four
days to pick out a black color
Halloween I was going to fifth grade
that's crazy because I don't remember
seeing Airwalk advertisements it's just
it got it kind of popular but I first
saw it at like skate shops I thought in
the skate man like Transworld a story
Transworld magazine mm-hmm and I would
see it in like all the skate magazine
yes but I've never seen it like
mainstream though you had to know your
shoe [ __ ]
yeah because California and Santa
Barbara is like a skate oh yeah
everybody wore skates er there's so many
chucks globes all the shorties well yeah
and then what's that something
industries with the water like the flame
God worst of all I think it's a World
Industries World Industries independent
well cos in the movie I would go to warp
tours and [ __ ] and like everyone man I'm
I remember the first time I came with
some Jordans I was like my first pair
Jordans ever because my parents could
never afford like Jordans for me yeah
and then one year I think I was in
seventh or seventh grade I saw these
Jordans that I really liked my dad kept
seeing me going back to them but cuz out
but I was like now I'm gonna get these
little like $50 Feliz I don't want to go
to Georgia Jordans are like a hundred
bucks they're like ninety hundred bucks
oh my god that's like you like those I
was like I mean I mean I guess they're
cool so he got me for my first one ever
and it was like like I came back to
school with the New Jordans oh my god is
what it feels like in with the new J's
how old are you
it's like seventh grade I want to say
well you miss have been popular I was
you know I never really got into Jordans
because like I said I didn't really grow
up with them you know I don't know like
the numbers or the names just wanted
that one yeah there's like a few I'm
like oh those are really nice I must
look cool yeah yeah but I was never like
you know some of these people they know
that release Dave stains all that [ __ ]
not really the colorways and I really
yeah so back to the subscription box oh
yeah they're saying they pick shoes from
Nikes and converse shoes how could they
own them you know the same company they
also own Hurley - really like you
Wow they're like the Disney of shoes who
owns Skechers Kim Kardashian that's you
really yo did you know the sketches are
like poppin yeah cuz every time I'm
thinking like who the [ __ ] where
Skechers I walk by like a Costco size
sketcher like know all about whatever
the like influencer girls are doing on
Instagram so like white sketches got
like really popular this year or last
year or whatever and that's like the 18
to 25 year old range if whatever those
girls are wearing or 60 and even like
I'm popular right now yeah I'm gonna be
popular is kind of what they're yeah
like big white contacts feelings
everywhere those don't hate I'm not
eating but it's like the razors okay I
think it's a good look
okay okay oh my god thank you I don't
like them I know you don't but then you
almost got sold on them but you actually
welcome really well I like to dad you
you really do but um anyway what velcro
nah but I mean it was like you they
could have them I like them because they
like they make your legs look slim cuz
it's like chunky like this and then it's
like boobs oh I thought it man you're
talking on Steve I like dad shoes on
Steve no no on me make those CVS ones
with the [ __ ] like all orthopedic
yeah yeah that's what I thought you're
talking about those - shoes I wear those
are pretty cool yeah I tell about this
[ __ ] well okay so I told you guys about
children over three years old
Oh show much they grow in size right but
for toddlers under 16 months they grow
more than 1/2 a foot size every two
months and from 16 to 24 months they
grow an average of one
half a foot size every three months and
from 24 to 36 months it's one foot sites
every four months
so then slow down once they hit over
three years old
we just bought tyka shoes that are like
four sizes too big so when he starts
walking if he walks oh we're you that's
not good I know but not he's he grew
into man I was wasp good but but yeah it
can be a [ __ ] them up
yeah but he's more barefoot I can't
believe you're even listening to what
the [ __ ] he says cuz he's like he
doesn't even know what's going on his
shoes the red bands those fit him like
one size they were like they were like
there were like two fingers like in
front of his toes he's tripping over
like he's ronal mcdonald but the neither
perfect
I mean Tyga probably the same size shoe
you guys almost the same the big boss
you know I feel like I mean this is my
own personal theory and I'm not gonna
show you my toes cuz I need to do it no
but I think I'm hiding up but I think my
babies so I think because of my parents
only measuring my shoe if they fit me
from the big thumb mic cuz I'm the my
toes are the ones were the second
fingers like this so mine actually
curves like this because I think when
they would want you to know no I'm not
gonna show you are they got them too
small because they were only checking
from the big time like this is my big
toe right yeah so this one it curves
down and for the longest time when I was
younger I'm not self-conscious about
anymore it's just that right now I need
to get a pedicure but I used to be so
self-conscious on my toes because of
that that makes sense
my toe is is deformed a lot of people
have that it's like having an innie or
outie it's like you either have that toe
or you have the one that's like this
one's no but not just rehearsing
because her parents forced her feet into
small so be like this right like this my
big talk so it's supposed to be like
this and like straight if if they got my
shoe Network yeah but now this is like
curved down who's all trying to fit in
with the other toes it's got a shriek
just a little bit yeah kill I even I
don't shrink to fit in I deserve that
buster but yeah I hated my feet and so I
remember like when I was way older I
would get compliments on my feet and I'm
like why and then that's how I kind of
got over it cuz people I assign you like
your wiki feat rating is like you know
her second toe is like [ __ ] feet
pictures of our feet and I were just
pictures of any celebrities foot and
they put it on theirs just for people
with foot fetish so knowing that someone
jacks off to your feet gave you
confidence yeah so now I'm like could
you grew up thinking like it sucks and
you're like wait you want to come on
these like two feet to so I'm like well
it wasn't like crazy crazy but that gave
you confidence our soul mates
[Music]
[Music]